if you know every show on netflix and
you're broke you have a problem you're
lazy if you know every hit song that
comes out and you're broke you're lazy
if you know every single post on social
media of other people's lives and you
don't have another hustle that you're
working you have to accept the fact that
you're lazy let me explain let me go a
little bit deeper with this on my own
personal life
my hip hop
music stops no three
mine stops in o3 my night life stops in
o3
my chasing of women doing the way i did
stopped in o3
my desire to want to watch and consume
every single sporting event that i never
missed a lakers game from the moment i
came to the states and when i joined the
army boot camp obviously you can watch
tv but then afterwards i've never missed
a laker game from the age of being 12
years old coming to the states to the
age of being 24 years old 23 years old
lakers was my religion sports stats was
my religion and i was broke and my dad
kept having heart attacks and my dad
worked at a 99 cent store on manchester
and normandy while i'm working at valley
60 hours a week i'm working at bally's
i'm the top sales guy at valleys because
i wanted my dad to be done but i
couldn't make enough money i was making
three grand a month
but at the time when i was off
i wasn't working a side business
i was doing anything to entertain myself
we are fooling ourselves if we're going
to sit there and just put all the
responsibility
on the people who have succeeded and not
put any responsibility on the folks at
the bottom that we're going to say well
poor you
you're working so hard but then how do
you know so much about all these shows i
don't understand i've never watched this
montana what is this montana show what
what is this
yellowstone i don't even know i don't
know what yellowstone is i've never
watched the breaking bat i've never
watched the sopranos i've never watched
an episode of sopranos the only serious
i've ever watched from o3 till today is
house of card season one because people
kept telling me i got to watch it
so as much as we want to sit there
and say oh my gosh poor me poor this
poor that which i come from a family
where half of them were communist and
half of them were imperialist the one on
the communist side that's all they were
talked about their bible was communist
manifesto and the ones on the right they
kept saying you know
why don't you do something every time it
was more fun for me to talk to the
communist than it was to talk to the
conservatives because the communists
would feel sorry for me and it was safe
and it was warm it was faster it was so
much better every time i went to the
communists i'm like oh my gosh you know
it's them i'm like that's right
you're right and i would feel special
but every time i want to talk to these
suckers on the other side the
conservatives so what are you doing
about it why don't you make a change why
don't you pick up a book why don't you
get another job why don't [ __ ] you
don't understand this is unfair
eventually i'm 23 years old looking at
my bank account
broke and i said which philosophy do you
want to buy into pat which one do you
want to buy to then i chose so now
is there things on the leader side
that's happening as well sure but for us
to fool ourselves thinking people don't
have any options to make a change
wait wait so you skipped over the most
important part okay so you chose you did
so what how did you get from bally's to
here like
walk me through that i went into
military and i got some discipline for
two and a half years because i didn't
have it thank you for your service now
anytime so i gotta i needed it so i
think many boys who are undecided
military is a good choice for them
i got out when i got out i worked at
ballets while i'm working at bally's a
guy named robbie solomon and my sister
my sister recommended me to read the
book how to win friends and influence
people
keep in mind i hate books till 21 years
old
anybody who knows me from high school
they know i've never finished the book
cover to cover never i've never finished
a book up i've never finished uh
uh what is it of mice of men
i never finished the uh uh
nelly petting as the lenny lenny was
letting the wrath of my son myself
what's the one that was then this this
1984 okay no no fahrenheit 451 are you
saying the books they assigned
uh listen i've never
finished a book cover to cover never
until 21
and robbie said read how to master the
art of selling by tom hopkins and i did
and then my sister said how to win
friends and influence people it's a good
book to read i read those two books one
i read those two books i sat there and i
said
this information is in a book for 10
bucks holy [ __ ]
what other recommendation you got next
one next one rich dad poor that you know
psycho-cybernetics you know power versus
force and i kept reading reading reading
reading reading reading reading and i'm
like this information is insane
then i started realizing i'm making way
too many excuses
i'm blaming the world for my problems
i'm not taking any responsibility some
of the mindsets that my mother's side
gave me is right some of it isn't right
some of the mindsets that my dad gave me
is right some of it isn't right i
stopped questioning things and i said
listen
if i want my life to change i got to
make a decision about it my parents
brought me here to be free my dad gave
me work ethic and next thing you know i
start uh
uh uh
i'm dating a girl named jamie who's
working on morgan stanley dean witter
and i said so why is it that you know
you have all these nice cars and she
says well i work at morgan stanley dean
what i said how can i get a job there
uh-huh she says you need to go to ucla i
said i'm not going to school
she said they're not going to hire you i
said i'm not going to go to college she
says you're not going to work at morgan
stanley dean witter i said let me see if
i can find a creative way to get a job
so i went and printed my resume okay and
i put a cover letter with a nice joke
getting creative
i faxed the 200 places goldman merrill
smith barney
td waterhouse morgan all of these places
i got 30 callbacks 15 of them left
because the joke was funny
the other 15 offered me an interview
three gave me offers at 21 years old i
started working on morgan stanley dean
witter a day before 9 11. so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]